what was your longest time that you
spent in jail over a year so at that
point I graduated to the penitentiary
County Jail is by definition for under a
year over a year by definition is prison
what was your longest 10 days when you
went down for this Penitentiary bid you
had to surrender yourself so I was
actually fighting the case the charge
stemmed from uh a prescription fraud bu
M had stole a a pad from a doctor
penciled out me a few perco setes so I
went to the the pharmacy down the street
and you committed frog yeah
totally you plad not guilty when you
knew damn well that you were guilty I
forget what my plead was but I was
fighting it and my lawyer ultimately got
me a sentence of 11 and 1/2 months to 23
but I was going to serve 30 weekends in
6 months house arrest